It's week seven,
there's only six bakers left,
and, boy, are they going to need
some skills today!
Hey Sandi, what are you doing?
I'm making pizza.
Paul's been teaching me how to toss.
He is an expert.
[Noel] For the first time ever,
it's Italian week.
Si, buongiorno. Come stai?
[Noel] ...with temperatures to match.
[door creaks]
[gasps] It is boiling.
[Noel] The bakers take on one
of Sicily's favourite street foods...
[Steven] What am I doing?
[Noel] ...tackle a classic,
that's not as simple as they think...
[Kate] Absolute disaster.
[Noel] ...and attempt
the most complex of Italian pastries.
Hell is what it is. Hell.
[theme music playing]
You sure this canal goes
all the way from Berkshire to Venice?
Yeah. It's one of Britain's
best-kept secrets.
Oh! A bit like the fact that we're doing
the first ever Italian week.
[Noel] It's shaping up to be
the hottest day in the tent ever.
[Kate] It is gonna be like Valley
of the Kings in that tent today.
Valley of the Cakes, I think.
[Stacey] Still here, can you believe it?
Can't get rid of me.
[laughs] Hopefully they won't
get rid of me this week either.
Star baker last week
was, yeah, it was sick.
But literally, I enjoyed it for one day.
I got to crack on with Italian week now.
Oh, Italian week.
It's like boot camp for bakers.
[Sophie] I absolutely love Italy.
Hopefully, by the end
of the weekend I still will.
Morning bakers,
or should I say buongiorno, bakers.
I am so excited about Italian week,
I have designed my own Italian shirt.
Italian Stallion.
Pony.
[Sandi] More of a pony, right.
So, Prue and Paul would like you to make
your version
of the Sicilian classic, cannoli,
so those little fried pastry tubes.
Now, apparently, every
self-respecting Sicilian mother
and even one or two with no respect at all
as her own version of this recipe.
[Noel] The judges would like you
to make 18
with three different flavoured fillings.
Obviously, your tubes must be identical.
Nobody wants mismatched tubes.
No, that is painful.
You have got two and a half hours.
On your marks...
Get set...
[both] Infornare!
Ciao, bellissimo. Isn't that Italian?
[imitating Italian accent] I don't know.
The one thing I have learnt is that
you respect Italian food and Italians.
The Sicilian cannoli is a tube
of deep-fried pastry
filled with a ricotta sweet mixture.
Just to make it a little harder,
we have told them they
have to have three different fillings.
The most difficult thing about making
a cannoli is getting the shell right.
It must be beautiful golden brown
and it must have bubbles
when you are frying it.
This is very characteristic of a cannoli.
[Prue] The luscious filling,
it mustn't run out.
You should be able to eat it
in your hand without a mess.
[Paul] All right, it's very hot today,
and we are asking the bakers
to make cannoli.
But they make them in Palermo
in the middle of summer
and that can be 45 degrees. No excuses.
So, I am just making my dough
for my 18 cannolis.
[Steven] We are gonna add vinegar.
Quite an unusual ingredient.
[Yan] So, this is the science bit.
Vinegar evaporates quickly
and creates bubbles.
[Sandi] Getting the balance right...
[Sophie] 160 grams.
[Sandi] ...is crucial to achieving
the perfect cannoli shell.
[Stacey] Don't want to put too much in.
Don't want it to be a sticky mess.
-Good morning, Liam.
-[Prue] Hi, Liam.
-Hello.
-Right, tell us all about your cannoli.
So, my cannolis are inspired by me,
basically, how I am as a person.
-[all laughing]
-I love that. It's a narcissistic cannoli.
So, my mates say that I have
a cheesy sort of sense of humour,
so I'm going for
a lemon cheesecake cannoli.
And then I eat a lot of Turkish food
in my spare time
so my second one is,
like, inspired by baklava.
[Noel] As well as his
lemon cheesecake flavour
and baklava-inspired honey and nuts,
Liam's third filling
is marshmallow and chocolate.
My dad took me camping
a couple of years ago.
Camping always reminds me of, like,
marshmallows and, you know, chocolate.
I love the idea of the flavours.
Have you been practising?
Yeah, 100%. I don't know how many cannolis
I have been through this week but...
[Paul] You haven't been practising,
have you?
[in high-pitched voice] I have!
Don't you believe me?
One egg. Plus, yolk.
[Sandi] For Steven, every week
is Italian week.
[Steven] I have family in Italy.
Erm, my grandfather was Italian.
But unfortunately, it's not done much
to, er, to help me here today.
Because I don't think
I ever saw him make cannoli.
[Sandi] Steven's adding
Italian style to his cannoli
with coffee and hazelnuts, almond praline
and Italian lemon curd.
[Steven] The reason I'm using
Italian lemons
is not just because it's Italian week,
but because they are incredible,
the flavour and the smell.
They do produce some incredible food
and that's why we love it.
Hello, Stacey. What are you doing?
What's your cannoli?
I have a jam roly cannoli.
[Sandi chuckles]
It was jam roly-poly cannoli
but I took out the "poly".
[Noel] Stacey's also making
cheesecake and tiramisu fillings.
And she is adding cocoa powder
to her dough.
I decided to do a new twist.
How are you going to know
when your cannoli shells are cooked
because they are going to be
brown, aren't they?
[Stacey] Yeah. I just sort of know.
I feel like I know. I mean, I've done--
But I might not, we will see.
[Steven] This is gonna chill out
in the fridge.
I'm just gonna start my fillings now.
[Sandi] The bakers
are aiming for flavours
that will make their cannoli
truly eccezionale.
[Liam] I am just creaming together
my marshmallow meringue
and then my other batch,
walnuts and pistachios.
[Kate] I'm doing Kate's happy hour
Italian cocktail cannoli.
-This is my favourite drink of all time.
-[Kate] Have a bit.
Kate's mini bar is officially open.
[whispering] Oh, it's so good. So good.
[mimics martial arts grunting]
[Sandi] Kate' s cocktail
flavours will include
limoncello, Negroni and espresso Martini.
[Kate] It's not a proper night out
if you don't have at least
three espresso Martinis.
What you don't want to do
is put too much alcohol in it,
it just overwhelms everything.
I had one once, an espresso Martini,
and at the end of drinking it I gave away
all my jewellery to strangers.
Terrifying drink.
[Noel] Kate's not the only baker
heading for the cocktail cabinet.
These flavours have come from a night out.
[Sandi] Yan's filling one with Amaretto
infused mint, rose and lime.
Another with honey and Amaretto.
The third is passion fruit and vanilla.
And like Stacey, she is also adding
cocoa powder to her dough.
Do you get the tell-tale bubbles
on your cannoli?
-Yes, I do. Yeah.
-You do.
But what I'm finding is, I can't see it
when it turns the correct colour
to take them out,
so I'm relying on instinct.
Now, I'm just making the base
for all 18 cannoli across three flavours.
[Stacey] The thickener,
that is the most important thing.
Hopefully, my filling will be nice
and tough and not fall out of the tube.
[Liam] And when I add the ricotta--
It's the ricotta-based one.
[Sandi] Ricotta is the traditional base,
and most of the bakers are sticking
with this Italian favourite.
[Steven] I don't want to play around
with classics,
especially Sicilian, because I imagine
they would probably get quite angry.
[Kate] I am doing ricotta.
I just didn't want a crowd of angry
Italians saying that's not traditional.
"What is she doing? She's messing around."
Probably find a horse's head
in my bed the next day if I did that.
[Sandi] But one of the bakers...
We are not here to do exactly
as per the Sicilians,
we are here to sort of put our own spin
and adapt recipes.
[Sandi] ...isn't afraid
to take on tradition.
Are you using Sicilian
sheep's milk, ricotta?
I'm not using any ricotta.
[Noel] Sophie's filling one
with Amaretto and almond,
another with limoncello cream,
and the third with a mix
of chocolate and hazelnuts.
Where is the ricotta?
I am using mascarpone.
What? In a cannoli?
-Yes.
-Why?
I think the texture's a lot nicer.
-[Paul sighs]
-Oh, God. What?
It's a cannoli. It has ricotta in it.
[Sandi] Does it have to be ricotta?
'Cause it's like an apple pie
has obviously has got to have apple in,
you can't make it with pear.
It's highly unusual.
It's not really that weird.
It is, if you are in Sicily.
How does this set then?
[Sophie] I am using gelatine.
Gelatine as well.
Are they still going to be
recognisable cannoli?
They will definitely be cannoli.
They're a little twist.
Bakers, according to the pasta clock,
you are half-way through your challenge.
I can assure you,
this guy is usually pretty accurate.
[Sophie] I've got my dough.
I'm passing it through the pasta roller.
This gets rolled out quite thinly.
[Liam] Ugh...
[Yan] What's important is that it's thin
enough for it to be nice and light,
but it's thick enough to make bubbles.
It needs the bubbles.
[Sandi] It's a balancing act...
Do I look like I know what I'm doing?
It's just how thin am I gonna go?
[Liam] I've gone for, like,
a one-millimetre thickness.
[Sandi] ...too thick and the pastry
won't cook,
too thin and the bubbles won't appear.
There's a set of rules
that you have to follow,
and if you don't then you get stung.
Right, cut it.
Then I'm gonna roll it up.
-Are you all right?
-[Liam] Er, this is hot.
The winner of this gets to lie down
in a child's paddling pool
full of ice-cold water.
Everyone should lie down
in a child's paddling pool.
-Ah...
-[Sandi] It's quite nice, isn't it?
Today the tent is hotter than Palermo.
And they are deep frying, poor things.
[Noel] It's about to get even hotter.
[exclaims]
[Kate] 'Cause what you want to do
in this heat is put more clothes on.
Don't want to burn myself.
[Yan] Health and safety first.
If we are splashed with hot oil,
it's gonna really, really hurt.
Let's do this.
In you go.
[Stacey] This bit is the most
important bit.
I just hope they don't separate.
[Sophie] Seal the edges.
You don't seal them,
just comes straight off the form
and floats to the top like a poppadom.
Great, it's poppadom week.
Why did that just ping off the mould?
I'm not impressed. Oh, God!
Some of them are just floating up.
Right, so that is one minute, 15.
That's not enough.
Ooh.
[Yan] I can't tell when it's done.
What I do find fascinating is Stacey
and Yan are adding
a little bit of cocoa powder
to the mixture. It's quite dark.
[Prue] How will they know when it's fried?
I tell when I'm deep frying
something by the colour.
[Noel] Are you all right?
[Yan] Oh, dear. That's not good,
and this is what
it's not supposed to look like.
It was a shame because
that was a good-looking one.
It's not the day, is it?
No. Yeah, this is-- I totally want
to do this on a really hot day.
Do you want me to somehow block the sun?
If you could that would be great.
I'm gonna put a call in to the moon.
-[Yan] Thank you, my darling.
-See you in a bit.
[Steven] They're making bubbles.
We want the bubbles
on the surface of the dough.
[Stacey] Bubbles are really important.
Some of them haven't got
as many bubbles as I would like
so I'm gonna do those ones again.
And I really don't want
to run out of time.
[Steven] Right. Fillings, that's mashed-up
almond praline.
[Kate] Chocolate espresso one is underway.
[Liam] Lemon cheesecake.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
[Stacey] You see, these are better.
I've got 15 minutes,
and I'm not gonna have time
to fill them if I don't get on.
It's weird, it's not as thick
as it is normally.
As soon as it hits the really hot weather
here it's getting quite liquid already.
[Kate] Oh, my God!
It's all coming out the sides.
[gasps] This is a disaster.
Absolute disaster.
[exhales] Stop shaking.
[Steven] I think I'm one short.
I have lost a shell.
Bakers, you have just ten minutes.
[gasps] Under pressure, immense pressure.
[Noel] Hi, Stacey. I'm coming in
but only briefly,
-and I'm moving.
-Okay.
-[Stacey] Okay. I'm going out.
-I'll come in, you go out.
Sorry.
His little tube's fallen off.
What am I doing?
Oh, man.
[Noel] You have got one-minute, bakers.
Sixty seconds to make it count,
you can do it, come on.
[Stacey] Can't believe what I've done.
The raspberries are supposed
to go at the end of these
and I've only gone and put them
on the other ones, haven't I?
[sighs] I'm so upset.
[Liam] My hands always shake when it comes
to, like, the last couple of minutes.
Bakers, time's up.
[Kate sighs] It's too hot.
[Stacey] They look a mess.
[sighs]
[Noel] The bakers' cannoli now face
the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-Hi, Stacey.
-Hi.
[Paul] Erm, is that not meant to be
like that, then?
[Stacey] No. Well, no,
and I'll tell you why.
What's basically happened is,
I've put the raspberries
on the end of the wrong ones.
I have dipped them in the wrong thing.
[Paul] It's formed bubbles. It has got
some bubbles on there. Tiramisu?
[Stacey] Yeah.
Great flavours, tiramisu.
[Prue] That cheesecake one
is absolutely beautiful,
but the pastry, it's a bit doughy.
Let's have a raspberry one.
A bit chewy. It shouldn't be chewy.
It's underdone.
[Prue] The pastry dough started off brown,
it's very difficult to tell
-looking at it when they're fried enough.
-[Stacey] Yeah.
[Noel] When you were holding that one
I couldn't tell what was fingers
and what was cannoli.
I think you should rename
them "Hollywood Fingers".
I think-- Do you know what?
I might do. Little stumps.
[Paul] Great shell.
[Prue] Really beautiful bubbles.
[Paul] Okay, let's look at this
marshmallow chocolate.
Wow, okay.
-Pouring out, isn't it?
-[Liam] Yeah.
[Paul] Probably not
the best choice for filling.
[Prue] Hmm. The lemony one is delicious.
Very good.
What's this one again?
[Liam] Pistachios, walnuts, ricotta.
[Prue] You can really taste
all of that. Sensational.
Cheers.
[Paul] Look at the bubbles
on that. It's perfect.
We have milk chocolate,
honey and almond praline.
[Paul] I love the flavour.
I think the praline in there,
particularly, is very good.
Steven, that mocha one
is very unctuous, lovely.
[Steven] This is Italian lemon curd.
[laughs] Very sharp.
Hmm, it is sharp.
The flavour of that with
the Italian lemons is delicious.
It's so sharp. Well done.
[Paul] My biggest concern is
I don't see too many bubbles on them.
Some look quite flat
without too much activation.
The pastry itself is very, very thin.
Remind us of this one?
[Yan] Mint, lime and rose.
Nice bit of tartness.
The flavours in that are lovely.
[Yan] Honey and Amaretto.
-[Noel laughs]
-I don't think that's meant to happen.
Bartender is always ready for you.
[Prue] Your pastry is too tender
because I didn't squish that hard.
It just fell to pieces.
The cocoa has fooled you
into thinking it's ready.
It probably could have done
with a little bit longer,
I just think your shells
have let you down.
[Prue] They're certainly not
quite identical, are they?
I mean, some of them are a bit shorter,
some of them are more bubbly.
Got quite a few bubbles on some of them.
This is the Martini one, is that right?
[Kate] Yeah, espresso. Yeah.
[Prue] Not very alcoholic.
I am a little disappointed.
I thought there would be more.
-[Paul] This one?
-[Kate] Limoncello.
[Paul] I think the alcohol is all right.
-[Kate] This is the negroni.
-[Prue] They are very orange-y.
[Paul] The ricotta in that one
particularly, you can taste,
-which is delicious.
-Thank you.
[Sophie] So, I have a lemon,
lime and ginger.
An Amaretto and almond
and a hazelnut and chocolate.
I've tried it with ricotta,
I just prefer the mascarpone.
[Paul] Right. It's gonna be fascinating
to try it with the mascarpone.
It's gonna be interesting to see
how this set in the shell itself.
This is a real test.
Hmm.
It doesn't pour all down you. It holds.
Yeah, very good.
This is not at all sloppy.
I think you might have converted me.
Awesome, thank you.
The almond and Amaretto,
mmm! That is heaven.
You got that slight dryness coming
through in the flavouring as well.
Yeah, I think you got three
very good cannolis there.
[Prue] If cannoli on the streets of Sicily
tasted like these, I'd be very happy.
I'm not sure I'd be welcome
after my use of mascarpone though.
[Noel] I think you should take that in
when you get your next
spray tan for the colour.
I think you should take that one in.
Thank you very much indeed.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[Sophie] I was a little bit concerned,
but that went a lot better
than I thought it was going to.
[Steven] He was playing with his jaw
and I thought
I know that feeling, you know,
when you eat something really sharp,
it gets you right here.
You cannot afford even to mess up
a little bit here now.
Every single challenge counts.
It's very, very, very stressful.
[exhales]
Ciao, bakers.
It's time for Italian week's
technical challenge.
Set for you by the lovely Signora Prue.
Do you have any advice
for the baking bambinos?
[Prue speaking Italian]
Well, I don't think that could have been
any more helpful.
[Noel] Judges, I'm gonna have to ask you
to leave the tent, please.
Prue, you can get on with your novel.
Paul has enrolled in a mime class.
[Sandi] For today's technical challenge,
Prue and Paul would like you to make
an Italian classic... Pizza!
We want a perfectly made Margherita.
[Noel] You've got an hour and a half.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
[both] Infornare.
I don't actually know what pizza is.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
[Yan] Basically, it's bread
with a bit of cheese on top.
What's the worst that could happen?
[Paul] So, Prue, why have you chosen
a pizza Margherita
as the technical challenge?
[Prue] Well, it's one of those things
that everybody thinks is easy,
and actually it's quite difficult
to get right.
The dough, it's got to stretch because you
want it to be really, really thin.
Have you left them with rolling pins?
No. We took their rolling pins away.
Thought they might fling it up
and get it round.
Bit of throwing, press of fingers,
bit of throwing...
That's the traditional way to do it.
You've got the classic Italian flag,
the white, the red and the green.
It's a sacred thing,
a pizza Margherita to the Italians.
It really is important if you are going to
use basil to put it on at the end.
Tastes better raw.
Has to be cooked
until it just begins to blacken.
Crisp dough on the outside,
bending over in the middle.
I think they will find it tougher
than they think.
"200 grams of flour,
half a teaspoon of fine salt,
two tablespoons of olive oil."
"Use the remaining dough
ingredients to make the dough. Knead."
I'm not really sure what a pizza dough
is meant to be like.
Prue said something like...
[speaks gibberish]
Ah, magra is thin.
[Yan] Bellissimo means beautiful.
But she also said croccante at the end,
which means crispy.
It's almost there.
Bouncing back. Come on, baby.
Give it like a couple more kneads
and then leave it to prove.
I don't think we need a proving drawer
in this temperature.
[Yan] I'm just gonna cling film it.
Right, prove it for an hour.
[Sophie] I don't know how long.
Usually, leave it till
it's doubled in size.
[beeping]
[Yan] Are you playing a video game, Liam?
It just says make a tomato sauce.
Which is helpful.
[Sophie] Chopping some garlic...
[Yan] They give you no quantities
on the tomatoes, olive oil,
garlic or lemon juice.
Shall I hold that for you?
You know how much we love you?
Mwah!
[Stacey] I'm not sure
how much garlic to do.
What do you think?
[Kate] Just put the tomatoes in.
Making sure it's properly nice
and thick and rich.
Now, they've got lemon juice
in there. Strange.
Shall I add the lemon juice at the end?
Might do a little bit now.
Pinch of caster sugar in. Balance it out.
[Stacey] I'm sure I've done it wrong.
[exhales]
[Kate] I've just chopped the end
of my finger off. On the fan.
[Sandi] Don't worry.
[Kate] Oh, God. I'm gonna faint.
[Sandi] Do you want a glass of water?
-[Noel] What happened?
-My finger went in the fan.
[Noel] Ooh!
[Kate] Someone's badly stitched
the health-and-safety inspector up.
[Sandi] It's all fine.
I've had a look and it's fine.
[Noel] Have you finished
massacring yourself?
[all laughing]
[Kate] Yeah, I once took a plaster off
and I actually passed out.
In terms of stories for dinner parties,
I wouldn't lead with that one.
[Sandi] Bakers, you are half-way through
your pizza delivery time.
What are you doing?
[Noel] I'm being the Leaning
Tower of Pizza.
-Okay, I'm going now.
-Okay.
[thuds]
[Sophie] It should be double in size
for a dough, so that's perfect.
"Shape and toss enough of the dough
to make a 30-centimetre base."
There is no rolling pin.
[Yan] Erm...
Sneaky. Sneaky Prue.
[Stacey] Of course
you don't have a rolling pin.
[Yan] I've never done free hand like this.
[Liam sighs]
The whole point of that, you've got equal
force going around all the entire pizza
so it brings it all out, but it could fall
on the floor and I have to make it again.
-Now?
-Not yet.
-No.
-Okay.
[Liam] It's too scary, man.
I can't... I don't know.
I might sort of flatten it out by hand.
I'm just gonna stretch it like this.
[Kate] I'm not gonna toss it,
'cause I can't 'cause I've injured myself.
-What about now?
-No. Not yet.
Go on. I'll take responsibility. Go on.
Go on, go on, go on.
-[Liam laughing]
-[whispers] Bit higher.
-I'm not doing--
-[both chuckling]
Ugh. Are you kidding me?
Oh!
It's too elastic now.
Knocked all the air out. Damn it.
I'm gonna prove it again.
One more toss and then I'm done.
[Noel] Hey, are you all right?
Basically, I'm down to the wire 'cause
I had to reprove my bread.
-It's fine, no worries.
-[Noel] Wow.
-You look like a pizza.
-I know.
Pretend to be my pizza, please?
I'll just lie down in front of Paul.
He'll prod you and go, "A bit overworked."
[Noel] Bakers, you've got 30 minutes left
to finish your yeasted flatbreads
topped with cheese and tomato sauce.
I do think it sounds better
if you just say "pizza".
[Noel] Bakers, you have got 30 minutes
left to finish your pizza.
[Steven] Pizza topping, here we go.
I think mozzarella should be
torn on to a pizza.
[Stacey] I think I should have done
big chunks of mozzarella.
[Sophie] Little bits of basil on the top.
If I put the basil on now, it will burn.
[Sandi] Bakers are using
traditional Italian peels
to get their pizzas into the hot oven.
And it's crucial
they're handled correctly.
That is super annoying.
Oh!
I should have decorated it on here
'cause it's just gone a funny shape.
Might have made it a bit shorter
in the process, yeah, I have.
That's gonna go in
for as long as it takes to cook.
Ten minutes.
[timer beeping]
[Sophie exhales] Gone in the oven.
My pizza's not a good shape but...
Oh, come on, come on!
[laughs nervously]
My pizza is stuck. For God's sake.
Oh, man.
Right, this is actual disaster zone.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my word. Absolute disaster.
[Yan] Ah, you beauty.
Good girl. How long have I got?
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
[speaks Italian]
Can totally do it. Come on.
You know we said we had no rolling pin?
There you go. Now I can toss it.
Thirty centimetres. Yes, baby.
[Yan] I can't remember. I don't think
they dust their peel, you know.
I haven't got time for this.
[Kate] Oh, look at it.
Oh, it's the worst thing ever.
-Let's fan ourselves.
-Can you fan me?
[Stacey] I feel absolutely horrendous.
[Sandi] Nobody can know how hot it is.
[Sophie] And of course,
we've now got ovens on and...
I was six-foot tall this morning.
Now look at me.
[Noel] That looks good.
[Liam] It's all right, innit?
I think I'm in the wrong business.
[Noel] Why? Do you think you
should be making pizzas?
Should be making pizzas.
[Yan] And it's in.
[Stacey grunts]
[Stacey] Not far off, you know.
[Steven] Yeah, it's good.
[Yan] Don't know if this is gonna work.
It's definitely time to come out.
I'm not gonna overcook this baby.
Be nice if it was a bit more rounded.
I've just taken some of the basil off,
'cause it doesn't really look very nice
when it's been cooked.
Bakers, that's the end
of your technical challenge.
Bring your pizzas up
and stick 'em behind your photo.
Be proud.
[Kate] Can I put mine in the bin?
Absolute disaster.
[Noel] Paul and Prue want to see
a classic home-made Margherita
with a crispy base topped with passata,
mozzarella and fresh basil.
[Paul] We will start with this one
over here.
Cooked on the bottom
and nice and soft in the middle.
I like the end of the slice
to just tip over a bit.
It did.
Hmm, it's got a beautiful flavour.
[Prue] And the dough is well-flavoured.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Bread is well flavoured.
-[Paul] Yeah, it's a nice pizza.
-Okay, very good.
[Prue] I think that pizza,
it is actually a little thick.
This is sort of a little bit
more like an English pizza,
rather than an Italian pizza.
[Paul] A little bit of tang,
nice tomato coming through
at the end. Not bad at all.
[Prue] So, this one, bit of a disaster.
I think mainly because the baker
put the topping on the pizza
before putting it onto the peel.
[Paul] It's very thick,
because it's concertinaed up.
[Prue] Hmm.
Raw dough is not particularly nice to eat.
[Prue] This one, I think
that the mozzarella
has been cut up too finely.
[Paul] When you chop up
little bits of mozzarella
you sort of lose it in the passata.
The whole thing is white, green, red,
the Italian flag.
Let's have a look.
[Prue] It's too thick. It's underseasoned.
It's just not very exciting to eat.
[Prue] Right, this one.
It's not absolutely perfectly round
but it looks really good.
[Paul] I like the basil on there as well,
the nice green basil.
[Prue] I love the fact
that the edges charred a bit.
Flavours are there, the tomato's good.
[Prue] And it's lovely and thin.
[Paul] Okay, moving on to another one
which looks like it's got stuck
on the peel again.
It's massively underbaked.
That is definitely undercooked.
But overall, you could eat most of them.
[Sandi] Paul and Prue must now rank
the pizzas from worst to best.
In 6th place is this one.
Whose is this?
Right, you got it stuck on the peel,
I take it.
I did.
Hence, sixth.
[Prue] Fifth place is this one.
Yan, it is undercooked
and a bit misshapen.
[Sandi] Stacey came fourth
and Sophie third.
It's very tricky between first and second.
In second spot is this one. Whose is this?
Well done, Liam.
Flavour's very good, tomato is good.
I think you made a nice pizza.
So, that leaves this one.
Steven, it's a beautiful pizza.
It's very thin, right amount
of scant topping.
Flavour's lovely. Well done.
[Steven] I love making pizza.
You know, I just went off
my own intuition and it worked.
I think I'm in the wrong business.
Should make pizzas. No, I'm joking.
No, it was really good, really good.
They spotted straightaway
that I had had issues
transferring it from the pallet thing
to the pizza stone,
and then it just all went wrong
from there, really.
[Yan] That plan of trying
to nail the technical,
to keep myself safe, didn't go to plan.
[Sandi] It's the bakers' last chance
to make a winning impression
on Paul and Prue.
The showstopper.
One more attempt
to keep their place in the tent.
[Noel] So, for the technical challenge
it seemed quite simple.
Pizza, it's a classic Italian dish,
but it's actually quite tricky.
[Paul] Steven, he smashed it,
he had the best pizza.
I think he's coming back 'cause he has had
a couple of weeks of really struggling.
The thing that pleased me so much
is that Liam's pizza was good.
It was vying with Steven for the top spot.
[Paul] He's got stronger and stronger
as the competition has carried on.
And Sophie actually,
she got the cannoli spot on.
[Noel] Who, for you,
is in trouble this week?
[Paul] I think Kate, she was last
in the technical.
[Prue] Yan didn't do very well either,
and her cannoli wasn't great.
Actually, Yan is in real trouble.
[Sandi] Stacey's hovered in the middle
for quite some time now.
[Prue] Stacey's problem
is that she panics.
She is like the John McEnroe of baking.
-[all laughing]
-She is, she is.
You might get a saucepan in the face,
or you might get a hug.
[Paul] Today is gonna be even hotter.
As temperatures rise, they fluster more.
When you fluster more, you make mistakes.
Buongiorno, bakers. Welcome to your second
day here in sunny Italy.
So for your showstopper Italiano,
the judges would like you to make
shell-shaped filled pastries
of Campania, sfogliatelle.
As I am sure you know,
sfogliatelle means "thin leaf",
so once baked, your delicate,
multi-layered pastries
should resemble crunchy rustling leaves.
The judges would like you to make
a batch of 24 perfectly flaky pastries.
But the filling is up to you.
You have four and a half hours.
On your marks...
Get set...
[both] Infornare!
Er...
50 grams of sugar.
I know this recipe off by heart.
I need to do really well today,
otherwise I'm in danger of going home.
Quarter final, it's like my absolute goal.
Sfogliatelle, it was developed
about 200 years ago in Italy by a nun.
It's layered, a bit like a filo pastry.
It's akin to a lobster tail.
When you bite into it,
it cracks in your mouth.
Inside has to be
the most luscious filling.
We've asked the bakers to make
12 of them one flavour,
12 of them another flavour.
The biggest mistake
they could do with this
is not building those layers correctly.
If they don't, they'll all just fall
to pieces in their hands.
It is so, so delicate,
even I struggled when I was in Italy
making it myself.
I think this challenge is pure murder.
[Noel] It's the most complex pastry
challenge ever set in the tent.
Oh!
Let's just leave it to the professionals,
or six insane bakers in a hot tent.
Knackered me out.
Right, my Sicilian lemons.
Boiled them for an hour.
[Sandi] The lemons are for Steven's
Sicilian-style marmalade.
The other half will be filled
with chocolate, orange and ginger.
[Paul] I love the idea of the flavours.
This challenge, what did you think
is the trickiest bit of it?
It's getting that, that flair of leaves.
And I was sort of researching
Italian chefs that were making these,
they were saying, "A, don't bother",
or "B, it's three days".
Four and a half hours is all you've got.
And you have to bother.
-It is doable.
-It is,
it's just very complicated
and can be extremely challenging.
Don't smile as you say that to me,
you picked it. [chuckles]
[Sophie] Got my dough
resting in the freezer.
So I'm just preparing my filling.
Semolina with some ricotta.
It's basically the thickener
for the, erm, sfogliatelle.
Everyone's doing this bit.
While the semolina's hot, I'm gonna fold
this chocolate so it combines into it.
So, tell us about yours sfogliatelle.
It's inspired by my trips to Canada.
During the Women's World Cup,
I went to a bakery every day to get
the most delicious lemon-blueberry scones.
[Noel] Yan's filling her other half
with maple pecan topped with bacon dust.
-Maple bacon, that's so Canadian.
-[Yan] Pecan.
How come you go to Canada so often?
'Cause my wife used to work
for a Canadian bank,
-they offered her a job over there
-Okay.
and she took redundancy,
'cause we are Londoners.
-Londoners through and through.
-[all chuckling]
[Liam] I've got
a maple-pecan sfogliatelle.
I know Yan's doing maple-pecan as well,
but she's added bacon.
To be fair, I had bacon in the fridge and
was gonna do it, but I was like, "Nah."
[Sandi] Liam's other filling
is orange, rum and raisin.
And he's found a unique way
to display them.
[Liam] So I've got, like, fake ice.
Looks like lobster tails, right?
So, the whole theme is like, you know,
just caught them from the sea.
My grandad used to deliver,
like, all different types of seafood
to, like, different restaurants,
you know, places across the country.
I love, like, the personal
sort of aspect to it.
I'm just starting to put it
through the machine.
[Sandi] To make just 24 sfogliatelle,
will take a lengthy 14 meters of pastry.
Is anyone else enjoying this?
No. Taxi?
It's very labour-intensive.
So much pastry.
If it tears, you just need to start again.
[Yan] It's a beast at the moment.
This can't be rushed.
[Liam] You okay?
[Yan] I'm okay.
Just put this through again.
So I'm starting to roll my dough now.
Erm, this is kind of the important bit.
This is what forms the leaves.
I'm just spreading some lard over it,
that's where you get, like, the flaky,
crunchy thing that you want.
[Steven] I'm gonna stretch it out.
This is gonna be one massive sausage.
Show us how you do it.
That's only that wide,
you need to get 24 out of it.
Anyway, so I'm just stretching it
out gently doing it,
'cause if you do it too much--
-[Prue] Make a hole?
-Yeah, you make a hole.
Why is it not a technical challenge?
Why is it a showstopper challenge?
Time. It takes hours and hours to produce.
Seems like a massive
technical showstopper.
It is, isn't it? Really hard.
[Paul] Have you seen one before?
No, my mum and dad
went on honeymoon to the Amalfi coast,
so I'm just going off purely
hearsay of what they say it is.
[Noel] Kate is filling half
with an Italian-style mix
of chocolate and hazelnuts
and the other with a less
traditional lemon and tahini.
-Tahini? Oh!
-Tahini.
Quite savoury, isn't it?
Took a bit of a risk,
but I have decided to do it
just because I like experimenting
with new flavours.
[Sandi] Sophie, though,
is keeping it simple.
Mango and passion fruit
is sort of a classic combination.
[Sandi] Her other filling is cherry,
almond and chocolate.
[Sophie] Don't want to go anything too
wacky with the filling or the flavours.
I just want to think about
getting the pastry right.
It looks like a pair of underpants.
[Stacey] Does it? Maybe yours.
Mine don't look like that, Paul.
[Prue] So, tell us about
your sfogliatelle.
[Stacey] I'm doing two different things.
Citrus and sultanas.
The second one, praline cream.
So I've made the praline
already, it's there.
[Noel] Stacey's giving her praline
crme pat sfogliatelle an extra boost
by lining them with choux pastry.
So, you are just putting
the choux paste inside...
Yes, and then hopefully
the choux pastry will puff up
and I'll be able to fill it.
The only problem is as soon
as you put them in the oven
they've got a mind of their own.
It's a gamble but I'm doing it. So...
Okay, so the ones that you practised
nine times out of ten they came out fine?
Hmm, the ones I practised,
nine times out of ten, they didn't.
[Sandi] Two hours in...
It's boiling hot in here.
Yes, we are trying to get
an Italian atmosphere for you.
Oh, right.
[door creaks]
[Sandi] The temperature
has hit 40 degrees...
[whispering] Oh, it is boiling.
[Sandi] ...and rising heat...
It's sticky, which I would prefer
that it wasn't.
[Sandi] ...makes rolling wafer thin pastry
easier said than done.
In this heat the last thing you want
is anything that's gonna melt.
Oh, the butter's melting.
It's just ruining me pastry, this heat.
I think it's beyond repair now.
[Sandi] How's it going?
[Stacey] It's splitting and it's hot.
Look at her, she's like
a machine over there.
-I'll just walk around like that for you.
-When I was at school--
When I was at school I always had,
"Stacey has potential
to do really, really well.
However, she doesn't concentrate."
When I don't concentrate,
things go wrong and unfortunately,
I could use about that much.
I just don't have enough dough.
[Noel] Bakers, you have got
one hour remaining.
[Steven] Cut it into 24 pieces.
[Noel] It's the moment of truth.
Time to see if their rolling
has been a success.
I'm just about to start
shaping my sfogliatelle.
It supposed to resemble a lobster tail.
A wheel of lamination.
[Sandi] Lamination is baker talk
for multiple layers.
[Steven] You see all those layers.
[Sandi] No lamination...
These are no good.
These are gonna be ugly-atelle.
[Sandi] ...may mean going home.
[Noel] Well, they look like lobster tails.
[Kate] What? What sort of lobster
have you seen?
I've got a pet lobster
and his tail is exactly like that.
[Kate] Please don't look at them.
-There's nothing to see here.
-They are fine, they are fine.
This is the choux pastry one.
Just so tiny.
I am sure somewhere in the lines
they said they wanted them to be
really small and very uneven in size.
[Liam] Yeah, mine aren't either,
I'm not gonna lie.
[gibberish] Don't even talk about yours.
[Stacey] God, they are looking
stunning, Sophie.
Thanks, mate. Just 23 more of them to do.
I'm gonna present 24 sfogliatelle
whether it...
It might well kill me,
but they never said you had to be alive
to take the judgement.
If you die, I will step in for you.
[gasps] Thank you.
I'll wear your apron.
Anything I could do to help?
It's not gonna be pretty.
[inhales sharply]
To be honest with you,
you are the least of my problems.
[both laughing]
This is hot.
They are sitting on an ice bath
just to stop it
literally melting in front of me.
[Kate] God, look at the state of them.
Oh, it's just absolutely melting.
It's just hell.
Just melting. Just not right.
[groans with frustration]
God almighty. Argh.
[Liam] Oh, God.
Will just be a makeshift one.
Oh, he has to come
at the one that flopped.
Look at my other ones in the fridge.
Please.
Such a wind-up merchant.
[gasps and laughs]
[Sandi] Bakers, you have 30 minutes.
[speaking Italian]
[Yan] So far behind.
Dough isn't behaving itself.
Oh. Argh...
I'm just gonna stick these in the freezer
for a sec because they've melted.
"Not worth the calories."
You don't want to get that from Prue.
Anyone for a canap?
Can you imagine if you got
that in the shop?
You would be like, "How much?
I'm not paying for that."
Let's just get this pain over
and done with, shall we?
[Sophie] I'm gonna put these
in for 15, 20 minutes.
[Steven] As the fat cooks it will
just push all the layers apart.
Come on, little babies, laminate.
It's all about when it goes
in the oven, how it looks.
You just don't know.
Time? Not doing great because I've got
16 minutes to put them
in the oven for half an hour.
I think the reality of this situation
is mine are pretty terrible.
[Yan] And they are going in.
Oh, no lamination.
I'm gonna get screwed over.
-No lamination?
-No lamination.
Oh, man.
I don't think "no lamination"
is the end of the world.
I mean, I'm not laminated
and I'm having a great time.
Can't look at it, they freak me out.
[Stacey sighs]
You have ten minutes. [speaking Italian]
[sighs loudly]
Have you got enough time to bake them?
God, no.
[timer ringing]
And in the hottest day of the year,
he puts gloves on.
[Stacey] It's a very stressful gig, this.
That is it.
Crapiatelli.
My choux puffed too much
'cause the whole thing has gone, ergh.
It's very depressing
-[Kate] Look at the state of them.
-[Noel] What do you want bigger?
-Bigger gaps?
-Bigger, everyone wants bigger.
-[Noel] Different colour?
-[Kate] Don't they? Let's be honest.
Just everything but what they are.
I mean, the filling does taste great,
I haven't got it in yet.
Let's just see if I can get it in without
it all spilling out.
[groans]
Absolutely ludicrous. It's melting.
[gasps]
Come on. Come on.
At least yours are cooked.
[groans]
The pastry cream
is leaking out everywhere.
Shooting out of every orifice.
That is weather-related.
And that's a bit of a problem for me
because the only reason why I did
the choux pastry in the first place
was to put the lovely crme pat inside,
so it's gone from disaster
to disaster to disaster.
Three, two, one. Now.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
Hope you drop them.
Can see her over there, cool as ice.
All else fails put on some icing sugar.
[Noel] Five.
[Sandi] Four.
[Noel] Three.
[Sandi] Two.
[Noel] One.
It's very upsetting
Bakers, that is the end of your
showstopper challenge.
[Steven sighs]
The last Italian challenge.
We can all have a nice espresso Martini.
[Sandi] Out you go from this
unbelievably hot tent.
[Stacey] It's definitely
the heat, it's not my fault.
[Kate giggling]
[Sandi] It's judgement time
for the bakers.
Liam, would you like to bring up
your sfogliatelle?
Liam, I think that presentation
is just fantastic.
Lobster tails on ice.
It's just amazing to look at.
They're inconsistent in size.
But I think you've got great lamination.
I think the layers are fantastic.
Maple and pecan. Mmm, delicious.
What have you got inside this?
Rum soaked raisins, orange zest.
[Paul] The orange comes
through in that one, actually.
[Prue] Flavour's lovely.
I know that took hours
and it's a hell of an achievement.
Steven, please bring up your sfogliatelle.
Proper showstopper.
[Paul] Lobster tail, excellent lamination.
Style.
Come on, substance.
Style box, ticked.
And substance.
-[Prue laughing]
-[Steven grunts]
The chocolate, the little bit of heat
that comes from the ginger is delicious.
[Prue] Sicilian lemons
taste really Italian.
It goes on flaking in your mouth
because the pastry is so perfect.
[Paul] What you have done is sfogliatelle
which are authentic.
I think you could sell them
in any pastry shop in Italy.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Great lamination.
You've got that classic lobster tail
running all the way through.
The time that you've spent on it,
you can see the intricacy.
So this is the cherry?
[Sophie] Yeah.
Hmm.
[Paul] It's got a nice bitterness to it,
which I think works inside.
I think that's like crisp leaves.
Chewing it you get
the passion fruit and mango.
It is quite a showstopper.
[Prue] I must say I'm a bit disappointed,
not only in the way they look,
the sfogliatelle,
but also because this was supposed to be
a showstopper presentation,
and it doesn't look
as if you're proud of them.
[Paul] Lamination,
there's big problems with that.
These look as though they've been sat on.
Hazelnut and chocolate.
Certainly got the hazelnut.
[Paul] Tahini and lemon.
Actually, it's quite pleasant.
If you close your eyes
and eat it, you think that's great.
But then you open your eyes
and see it and go, "Ah".
[Paul] You are not getting
much lamination.
Oh.
[Prue] Maple and bacon,
it's extremely Canadian.
Flavour's lovely.
But the consistency is quite doughy.
[Paul] The crme pat and the blueberry,
these ones are quite raw.
[Prue] You are obviously disappointed
and in a way,
we are a bit disappointed, too.
Bit of a mess.
Total mess.
Stacey, please bring up your sfogliatelle.
[Prue] Erm... Sfog...
[Stacey] Sfoglia-teenies.
So they're for the kids.
[Prue] Oh, I see.
The lamination is very poor,
and there is too much icing sugar
on there, which is unusual for you.
Normally, you smash something
like this and it looks good.
[Prue] It's the heat, I think.
[Paul] Citrus and raisin...
I like that filling.
I think it's the right degree
of sweetness.
[Paul] It's very runny for a crme pat.
You were so ambitious
to do a choux paste middle.
[Paul] Your nightmare's come true.
The choux bun has burst out and on the top
there you have raw dough.
I appreciate the fact
that it's extremely difficult to do,
but everyone is in the same boat,
and we have to judge accordingly.
I agree.
[Paul] And this one, I think
you have let yourself down a little bit.
I think it was close to, in old money,
100 degrees in the tent.
Have either of you ever worked
anywhere that was hotter?
I worked in Hong Kong in July
in an unairconditioned hotel kitchen.
I can better that.
When I was working in the bakery
and the temperature was 50 degrees,
all I had on were shorts.
When I was a fire juggler
I lived on the edge of a volcano...
But I got on with it.
[Sandi] So going into this, Sophie
and Steven both in a very good place.
Is that still the case?
[Paul] Yes, that's certainly the case.
[Prue] Both Steven and Sophie
are very skilful with their fingers.
[Paul] Liam's was a little bit tardy
on the overall size differences,
but the lamination he managed
to get, very clever.
So, Liam, Sophie
and Steven for star baker?
And who is in the danger zone?
[Prue] Yan's struggled, and she knew that.
I mean, she didn't achieve any lamination,
they were undercooked.
I mean, there was a whole heap
of things wrong with Yan's.
Yan's struggled, hasn't she, all weekend?
She has. I think Yan's had
a terrible week.
[Paul] I think Kate is there as well.
It did look hideous.
[Sandi] What about Stacey?
[Prue] Not worth the calories.
My ultimate test.
Fantastically well done to everybody.
I have never seen anybody have to do
such a tremendously difficult challenge
in this astonishing heat.
It was really, really tough.
It is my pleasure to announce
this week's star baker.
The star baker is the person
who brought the flavours of Italy
absolutely bursting into our mouths
with the cannoli and whose sfogliatelle
was a laminate perfection.
The star baker is Steven.
[all applauding]
Obviously, that means I have got
the horrible job
of announcing the baker who is leaving us.
The person who is leaving us
this week is...
Oh, my God!
[sighs]
Yan. I'm sorry.
It's okay. [sighs]
[Noel] We will always have Basil the Veg.
I am so sorry.
[Yan] That's okay, I don't...
Don't be sorry.
[Stacey] I thought it was me.
[Prue] I know you did.
I could see it on your face.
It was close.
[Yan] Oh!
You did really well.
Thank you.
I am amazed how far I have come.
It's been difficult, tough,
an amazing experience.
It's been the best.
[Prue] Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm not sorry. It's okay.
-I have had a wonderful adventure.
-Have you had a good time?
A totally wonderful adventure.
Thank you so much.
Poor Yan.
I mean, everybody loves Yan,
and I'm as sorry as anybody to see her go.
Come here. I love you.
-Come here
-[Yan] It's okay. Don't worry.
[chuckles] Oh, like... I'm still in shock.
I'm super excited,
but I'm super upset for Yan.
Absolutely gobsmacked.
Gobsmacked.
When they said "Yan",
I nearly fainted off my chair.
-[Yan] I knew. It's okay sweetheart.
-I am so sorry. I'm so sorry.
-It's okay. No, no.
-I'm shocked to my core.
-[Kate] Well done.
-[Steven] Thank you.
[Paul] Steven's back.
He had style and substance.
I am floating on that cloud again.
I've got all this way. It's mad.
Mad, mad, mad, mad. So good.
I feel proud, but more shocked, I think.
[theme music playing]